have to hold it Wow well I I can't
believe that I was actually gonna say
this well thank you the Academy for
recognizing my film and it has been an
absolutely incredible week I want to
congratulate all the winners here for
your remarkable films I want to thank
the faculty and my classmates at NYU
especially professor Marsh Iraq and
aviva slesin to bring me to the
wonderful world of documentary
filmmaking it has changed my life I want
to thank my composure my amazing
composer cell Alexander who is also in
the audience today we often work from
four o'clock in the morning to 12 in the
afternoon we had crazy work schedule and
he always managed to come up with great
ideas he's great please hire him as a
first-time filmmaker and the way man
crew um it was very difficult to make a
documentary about a desk and I wanted to
thank my family for their support
especially my mom who really showed me
what unconditional love was when I
thought I was at the lowest point in my
life the people I want to thank the most
are the subjects in my film they had the
worst experience of losing their only
children to a horrible earthquake and I
was extremely lucky that I can have them
open up to me I I know so much from them
about life about love about family about
this I think grief is a very personal
experience the 2008 earthquake was not
one incident that 19,000 people died it
is nineteen thousand individual
incidents that each of which claims one
person's life so I was blessed I was
able to be there to tell the story about
my hometown and about the voice and his
parents in China love without conditions
persistence and some luck
I think these are the reasons that I
were able to make the film I'm extremely
grateful that I'm able to share that
with you here today thank you very much